madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
évoquez ici notre politique étrangère
est toujours un exercice délicat notre
hémicycle est scruté par les
chancellerie étrangères mais lorsque
l'autocrate du Kremlin annexe les
territoires d'un pays souverain après
des parodies de référendum et use de la
menace nucléaire comme il le fait depuis
le 24 février en invoquant le précédent
d'Hiroshima notre parole doit être toute
de gravité
rappelons trois vérités d'abord il y a
un agresseur la Russie et un agressé
l'Ukraine
le narratif russe est une imposture le
traité 4 + 2 ne comportait aucun
engagement de ne pas étendre le temps si
cela avait été si important cela aurait
été évidemment couché sur le papier
la Russie bafoue les droits humains el
Bafou aussi sa signature dans le
mémorandum de Budapest de 1994 elle
garantissait les frontières de l'Ukraine
c'est si vrai que même un pays comme la
Turquie qui s'efforçait de respecter un
équilibre ambigu affer
les référendums d'annexion
quant à l'adhésion à l'OTAN des nations
d'Europe centrale et orientale c'est le
choix de peuple libre que rien ne
justifie d'empêcher le temps n'a jamais
envahi personne et les erreurs
américaines je pense à l'Irak n'ont pas
été commises sous la bannière de
l'Alliance
quant aux États-Unis si leur complexe
militarro industriel et leur industrie
pétrolière profiteront évidemment de ce
conflit c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
leur grande stratégie de pivot vers
l'Asie Pacifique cette guerre est une
tragédie pour tous l'Occident n'est sans
doute pas sans défaut mais il importe de
discerner l'essentiel de l'accessoire
rappelons aussi qu'il est chez nous une
cinquième colonne
à l'extrême gauche par atavisme
stalinien par anti-américanisme primaire
et par anticapitalisme furieux alors que
l'économie russe en a le pire visage
celui du capitalisme de connivence et de
prédation
à l'ultra-droite par fascination pour le
culte de l'homme fort et la défense de
prétendu valeur le conservatisme à sa
grandeur le préserver ce qui vaut
changer ce qu'il faut de d'israëlie
n'est pas sans noblesse
mais Vladimir Poutine l'ami de Kadirov
ne défend pas les racines chrétiennes et
le message d'amour universel des
Béatitudes il en est leur caricatures
grimaçante celle de la parabole du Grand
Inquisiteur de Dostoïevski qui ne sert
qu'à couvrir le pas des bourreaux dans
la nuit de boucha
enfin ne nous y trompons pas la guerre
déclarait à l'Occident comme un tout est
une guerre contre l'homme occidental
l'homme du libre arbitre et de la
délibération démocratique qui refuse les
assignations à résidence même s'il
n'oublie ni les limites de la condition
humaine ni son appartenance un tout
organique qui s'appelle la communauté
nationale
cette guerre est aussi une guerre contre
la France regardons ce qui se passe au
Mali avec Wagner ou semble-t-il au
Burkina Faso
alors que faire
continuer avec sang froid ne pas céder
aux bluff Beaba de la grammaire
stratégique de la dissuasion maintenir
et renforcer les sanctions d'autant que
les difficultés énergétiques qui
s'annoncent sont au moins autant les
conséquences de la crise en Ukraine que
des erreurs de politique énergétiques
commises depuis 2012
refusaient la facilité de l'égoïsme et
du pacifisme bêlant avoir en tête les
mots de Churchill vous aviez le choix
entre la guerre et la honte vous avez
choisi la honte et vous aurez la guerre
rappeler enfin et vous l'avez fait
madame le Premier ministre que nous
n'avons rien contre le peuple russe il a
toujours balancé entre le courant
occidentaliste et le courant slavophile
nous sommes hélas dans un moment ils
vend le terrible pas dans un moment
Pierre Legrand mais nous nous retrouvons
un jour sur l'année 20 j'en suis certain
négociant si nous le pouvons bien sûr
mais à la date et aux conditions fixés
par l'Ukraine car elle sait elle seule
qui paye le prix du sang pour ramener à
la raison
imperturbateur de l'ordre international
alors la France puissance d'équilibre
pourra jouer tout son rôle stratégique
concrètement cela signifie d'abord armée
l'Ukraine mais sans nous démunir car nul
ne sait de quoi demain sera fait la
décision dont s'est fait l'école après
de livrer des canons César prévus pour
l'exportation ou des véhicules Arceus
est excellentes et qu'on ne vienne pas
dire que c'est prolongé la guerre
heureusement que le Royaume-Uni n'avait
pas dit cela à la France Libre ayant en
tête les appels déchirants et désespérés
des maquisards du Vercors qui demandait
en vain des livraisons d'armes se disent
sont pour nous les frères de ceux du
Vercors
ensuite donner des signes de notre
résolution
notre prochaine LPM on sera un et notre
groupe mais monsieur le ministre je le
sais aussi sera très vigilant à ce que
nos armées soient dotés de tous les
moyens nécessaires pour répondre au
tumultes du monde
la référence aux années 30 est souvent
une paresse de l'esprit mais qui sont à
la rhétorique du diktat occidental au
coup de bluff réussi de Géorgie ou de
Crimée à l'obsédant une question des
minorités et durée découpage des
frontières celui-là ne peut échapper au
parallèle vertigineux de la
remilitarisation de la Rhénanie de l'âne
schluz et de Munich il est peut-être
plus tard que nous ne le pensons qui le
mieux vaut mieux réarmer en 36 que
d'attendre 1938 le temps du quoi qu'il
en coûte de l'économie est terminée
celui du quoi qu'il en coûte de la
sécurité à hélas commencer
enfin
promouvoir l'unité du monde libre
aujourd'hui rien ne peut remplacer le
temps sans l'aide américaine qui fournit
70% de l'assistance militaire les chars
russes tromperaient probablement leur
chenille dans le Bougue aux frontières
de la Pologne
notre présence dans le commandement
intégré et notre meilleur assurance pour
peser auprès de nos amis d'Europe
centrale qui savent hélas que sans les
États-Unis leur protection serait bien
fragile
et qu'on invoque pas à tort et à travers
les mânes du général de Gaulle quand il
s'est retiré du commandement intégré il
s'agissait de se repositionner dans le
concert des nations face à des
États-Unis englués dans le bourbier
vietnamien la France consacrée près de
4% de son PIB à la défense alors que ce
n'est que 2% aujourd'hui alors de grâce
pas d'anachronisme ne faisons pas parler
les morts retenons de lui qu'il n'est
pas de politique qui vaille en dehors
des réalités qu'elle est toujours
contingente mais causeurs cruciales il
faut choisir son camp comme il le fit
avec l'ambassadeur du RSS qui le mettait
en garde au moment de la crise de Cuba
et bien Monsieur l'Ambassadeur lui
répondit-il nous allons mourir ensemble
c'était la meilleure manière d'éviter la
guerre et de sauver la paix
l'Europe notre Europe a également tous
son rôle à jouer dans la sortie de crise
l'idée d'une communauté politique
européenne est à saluer dès lors qu'elle
permettra de rassembler
utilement sans provoquer des adhésions
prématurées ni opportunes ni souhaité en
l'état par les peuples de l'Union
quand les canons se seront tu il sera
temps de travailler à notre autonomie
stratégique car rien ne dit que le
tropisme asiatique de notre allié
d'outre Atlantique ne nous laissera pas
un jour fort démuni en attendant
l'unité de l'Occident et notre meilleur
garantie notre division sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine ou sur les sanctions seraient
en fait la seule arme entre les mains de
Moscou alors
en ces heures décisives
notre groupe sera comme il l'a toujours
fait aux avant-postes de la Défense de
l'Occident à vos côtés quand il s'agit
d'intérêt national
[Applaudissements]